Anthony beard recruiting an identity
donor persuading a man to sell him his
passport the first step in the scam
step two beard meeting a man who wants
to buy the passport a fugitive drug
trafficker
three was the clever bit Anthony beard
took the passport he'd just bought and
applied for a new one using the
fugitives photograph he claimed the
original passport had been damaged or
lost so long as the fugitive looked more
or less like the original passport
holder the scam worked
many of Britain's most wanted fugitives
bought the documents known as Foggs
fraudulently obtained genuine passports
the passport would be a Golden Ticket
whether you're wanted or whether you
want to go in and out the country uh not
seen by obviously law enforcement or by
borders it would be absolutely key to
running organized criminal Network
internationally and across borders it's
absolutely key to their business their
business structure come back
beard used a High Street shop to print
out the photos of his customers waiting
for passports Christopher zetek was the
go-between he found the buyers through
his contacts with organized crime groups
in London and Scotland
he and beard were bugged discussing a
potential passport customer
cannabis trafficker Jamie a court bought
a passport while hiding in Spain he was
once a suspect in the Stephen Lawrence
murder gun Runner Richard Burdette a
fugitive in Holland and cocaine Smuggler
Michael moogan in Dubai also used the
gang's passports a court Anthony beard
was jailed for six years and eight
months the judge said the gang had
enabled very Wicked sophisticated and
violent criminals to evade Justice zetec
was jailed for eight years Alan Thompson
described as the gang's dog's body got
three years the home office said the
sentences demonstrated the government's
commitment to tackle and dismantle
criminal gangs threatening Public Safety
for profit
Martin brunt Sky News at reading Crown
Court